who would have thought tom brady playing
for the tampa bay buccaneers i've typed
it a few times over the past several
days and my fingers don't want to type
buccaneers quarterback tom brady
well
it's crazy it is uh it's really cool too
though i gotta say i mean it just adds
excitement to this nfl offseason i don't
think you know in my heart of hearts i
really didn't expect him to be on a new
team i thought new england would you
know
you know just swoop in on the at the
23rd or 24th hour and make him a deal
and okay it's brady the patriots let's
make one more run but man there's the
different storylines about this mike i
mean tampa's never had this type of
quarterback or superstar on their team
that's going to add so much energy to
that city and then the potential of this
football team and this team even before
tom brady had big time potential i mean
one of the best front sevens in football
some young studs in the secondary we
talk about the weapons they have on the
offensive side of the ball so uh it
really has a chance to be awesome uh
it's gonna be great to just see brady in
that uniform and see a whole new look
for the nfl this season
and i don't think you were alone in that
concern that and not that it was
concerned per se but the idea that the
patriots were going to swoop in at the
last minute and get this done peter king
points out in football morning in
america that brady showed some interest
in the cults but the colts did not
reciprocate and if i am the cults i am
concerned about another josh mcdaniel
situation right
i'm concerned that the planets are going
to line up just right for me to get tom
brady and just as it's time for tom
brady to put his name on the contract
what's gonna happen here come the
patriots to snatch him away from me just
like they did with josh mcdaniel so that
may be and i don't know that to be the
case but that may be one of the reasons
why the colts are paying phillip rivers
25 million for one year and brady is
getting 25 million per year on a
two-year deal from the bucks dollar for
dollar brady's a better deal but i think
the colts at some level again i don't
know this but i think that there had to
be some hesitation to go down that path
because of what happened with josh
mcdaniels chris well maybe and you know
again as much as we like philip rivers
he ain't tom brady and the spectacle
that comes along with tom brady i just
don't know if every team was welcoming
of that or always wants that you know it
can overtake your organization in a lot
of ways let alone as we talked about i
do think some teams were afraid of brady
because they were afraid they might get
exposed where they might go you know tom
brady comes into it comes into the
office and you know at the end of the
day he looks at his watch and he's like
wait coaches are leaving the facility
right now they would never leave this
early in new england wait this is the
way you do it here with this team well
they would never do it this way in new
england i think there was a number of
people throughout the nfl that were
scared of that aspect of tom brady that
they would get exposed uh through that
plus mike let's not forget philip rivers
frank reich do have a history uh in
front and you know philip rivers
understands that often so i'm sure that
made them feel more comfortable as well
that's a hell of a point though and i
hadn't thought of that what that when
tom brady show we we thought it from the
perspective of tom brady walking into a
new building saying holy crap they don't
do things here the way they do them in
new england but then you have to be
concerned at some point brady's gonna
put that out there and you know because
look
whenever the patriots dominate right
what's the knee-jerk reaction when an
owner says to a coach why do you get
your butt kicked by the patriots all the
time the coach says because they cheat
and that narrative has been around for
15 years now well if all of a sudden tom
brady is getting a peek behind the
curtain at how hard these other teams
work or don't work all of a sudden
there's a different narrative the
reality is bill belichick and company
are busting their butts while these
other folks aren't working quite as hard
yeah i mean i think that's a very big
reality mike you know not that i've been
in every building in the nfl
but i think you know me personally or if
you talk to other people around the
league who have been in a number of
facilities along with new england they
would tell you that when you go in there
it's got a different vibe and feel than
any other facility in all of football it
just does and that's because of the
culture set forth by bill belichick and
everybody else but yes it's different
it's run differently it's as detailed as
you can possibly be in a professional
sports setting and then yeah belichick
of course is the general that ship and
it's just a different thinker and a
different man all together so there's
nothing that can compare to what's being
done in new england hey brady was
awesome we get that but new england the
machine they have rolling there is
magical and that's why they've also
dominated for 20 20 years not just brady
it's all of it all together
hi i'm mike tarico and thanks for
watching make sure to hit subscribe for
the latest news and highlights from nbc
sports